we begin with President Trump on the
verge of a truly historic diplomatic
triumph as his tough talk appears to be
paying off the leaders of north and
south korea this was wild agreed in
principle today to remove all nuclear
weapons from their countries and to work
toward formally ending the state of war
that has existed since the 1953 truce
trump was ecstatic over the news
tweeting early in the day korean war to
end the president later acknowledged
there was much work to be done but he
sure sounded optimistic a lot of good
things are happening with respect to
North Korea President Obama told me when
I had t1 meeting with him he said that's
your biggest problem that's gonna be the
most difficult thing you have and
honestly I wish it was handled earlier I
wish it were handled by another
administration years ago I'm not just
talking about President Obama I'd go
back to any administration you want but
over the last 25 years this should have
been handled a long time ago not now
this should not have been left for me to
handle but we will handle it we're
handling it well so is it time for
Trump's critics to concede that his
tough Rocketman talk on the sanctions
North Korea actually made a difference
here Republican congressman Luke Messer
has been urging colleagues to support
wait for it a Nobel Peace Prize for the
president he joins us now from Fort
Wayne Indiana and former Trump campaign
adviser in China policy expert Mike
Pillsbury is going to be with us as is
Asia policy expert Riley Walters of the
Heritage Foundation great panel this is
I never thought I would see this in my
lifetime I have to say guys the idea of
the North Korean dictator crossing the
Xia DMZ to meet the South Korean leader
obviously speaking the same language
meeting together embracing at one point
after the handshake after they had their
meeting again this is initial still and
its initial phases but congressman
I have to say I think the only person
who could have gotten us to this place
again we'll see where it goes
butts Donald Trump because of his
unconventional approach to negotiations
and frankly his tough talk the you know
you didn't know if people cuz they're
gonna launch a nuclear war unilateral
first strike mr. president he's like no
but we're gonna solve this congressman
how did Donald Trump manage to get us
this far well it is extraordinary
and you know Laura I've been saying for
a couple months now if North Korea
actually ends its nuclear program and
you bring peace to this peninsula after
70 years Donald Trump deserves a Nobel
Peace Prize the only reason that the
evil North Korean dictator is coming to
the table is because there's a new
sheriff in town and president Trump's
Twitter diplomacy his working his tough
talk is making a difference it's
bringing both North and South Korea to
the table and China too of course we
have a long way to go here but these
events of the last 24 hours
are extraordinary and almost impossible
to overstate it's a very big deal and it
is happening because of president
Trump's leadership we're gonna talk
about the Chinese involvement in all
this because we cannot overlook the fact
that we have major administration
officials going to China on Tuesday Bob
light hyzer the USTR and also of course
we have Steven unshin and other senior
level members of the administration
going to talk trade but Mike posed where
I want to go to you I want to do a
flashback it's kind of flashback Friday
today and played for our entire panel
the scene from the Nobel Prize ceremony
involving newbie Barack Obama let's
watch as the audacity to to hope and the
tenacity to make this whole come true
that is what makes him so important by
his own behavior and leadership he is
demanding that we all take over share of
responsibility for a global response to
global
challenges we congratulate there for
this year's laureate President Barack
Obama on what he has already achieved
Mike Pillsbury that was in ten and a
half months he he was getting people to
expect accept responsibility for facing
global challenges now if that's the
benchmark Mike Pillsbury then Donald
Trump regardless of what happens has to
be almost a shoo-in for the Nobel I
think the congressman is right here well
I agree obviously perhaps the president
Trump has earned two Nobel Peace Prizes
as you know the authority of these Peace
Prizes is somewhat in doubt it's
committee committee of five who are
chosen by the Norwegian Parliament and
they tend to be retired members of the
Norwegian Parliament so they've made
some real mistakes over the years people
whose Nobel Peace Prize was not earned
the case of President Trump this is a
tremendous success the only problem is
the degree of pressure he used to get it
may turn the stomach's of some of the
Norwegian members of parliament don't
forget he had nuclear aircraft flying
toward North Korea
he had the discussion with the South
Korean Defense Minister that we might
return our nuclear weapons to be
deployed again in South Korea as many as
800 or more other kinds of pressure
obviously was the massive very focused
sanctions even on the oil family in the
north so this is not your ordinary
idealistic make a speech kind of Nobel
Peace Prize candidacy this is someone
who really got results but the results
but the results came only through
pressure I think the Chinese also helped
and frankly president Trump linking
trade and the delegation going next week
to helping with North Korea that was a
very bold gesture heavily criticized by
the left-wing media but it looks like it
was a stroke of genius the Chinese
helped us on North Korea who would have
thought Laura now I think I think that's
a great point Riley I want to go to you
on this I I frankly am I'm a little bit
worried on the linking of China trade to
North Korea obviously the choice between
thermo
nuclear war or the China 2025 program
where they dominate every major industry
and that's I mean it's it's it's a it's
not the easiest of concerns to look at
when you look at them both
we can't allow China to dominate
high-tech we cannot allow China to
dominate 3d printing space weaponry
commercial aviation but that is they're
subsidizing gold they're doing that
across every industry and I'm worried
that that Donald Trump is so focused on
the North Korea deal that will let up
the pressure on China that also was
necessary but so far he's had great
judgment there's definitely a difference
in opinion on what the sort of immediate
threat from North Korea and the future
threat from China sort of represent
obviously last night was historic event
this is setting up toward the upcoming
meetings between the leader of North
Korea and Donald Trump China's role in
this coming going forward is is
skeptical I think I mean you know we you
know Donald that's sorry the president
of China Xi Jinping had the North Korean
leader come visit him almost out of the
blue in the middle of the night just a
couple months ago to preempt his visit
or started the North Korean leaders
visit with South Korea and the United
States and so I think definitely the
maximum pressure that the United States
has been applying has been both you know
influencing and incentivizing North
Koreans to come to the table and the
Chinese to reciprocate congressman I
want to play for you and the panel a few
of our favorite friends on the other
side of the aisle who refused to give
President Trump even a modicum of credit
here let's watch people shouldn't talk
about Donald Trump or anybody in North
or South Korea winning the Nobel Peace
Prize my message for President Trump
tonight is Curb Your Enthusiasm don't
setup unrealistic expectations for the
summit that cannot possibly be fulfilled
because if you do have these
expectations and it fails that may
actually draw us closer to war this was
to show that nobody else is in control
and that China and the United States is
not in control that the two Koreas are
seizing the process
yeah they just sue a smile came together
it was just like pixie dust and they
came together that that last comment I
mean of all the dumb comments I've heard
that last comment was among the most
moronic congressman well one the
president's being strong towards China
that's part of why we're even in this
position in the first place
China they are ripping us at the border
your return Mike Pillsbury knows this
and just because they've helped on North
Korea doesn't mean we can let them off
because they are always to dominate all
these industries absolutely and we are
where we are because this president
shown strength and you wait he's going
to show strength towards China you
already see them cut caving in but he
here's the deal right
the withering criticism of folks on the
Left could you imagine how they would be
behaving if Barack Obama was president
and you had events like last night it's
you know I'm running for the United
States Senate against Joe Donnelly a
Democratic senator who like all those
others on the Left have criticized this
president's diplomacy look Twitter
diplomacy is working Norton North Korea
has come to the table in a way that most
of us would have never imagined just a
few months ago you cannot overstate how
big a deal last night was of course
there's a long way to go but we are here
because America is safest when America
is strong and with this president
President Trump we are strong again on
the world stage and to have events like
would have happened in the last 24 hours
is just another big step in the right
direction and I agree with you or listen
we've got to be strong towards China
this president is stepping forward and
getting tough on China in a way that
hasn't happened in decades and I'm just
confident he's gonna continue to do it
look it's that great instinct this guy
wrote the art of the deal he's a
remarkable leader